[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants j'espère que vous
avez été sage aujourd'hui
but we pas trop trust alors je propose
que nous fassions tous ensemble un beau
concert ou aux consoles patron mais oui
un vrai concert le jour ont chacun d'un
instrument de musique différents
je peux lui oui d un rythme au gros
nounours
dès que vous êtes prêts nous commençons
[Musique]
bonsoir le genre au voisin les noces
on apprit cap et musique et on va la
jouer tout de suite à ces toiles de nous
oui saison au plus haut
[Musique]
c
où je prends le musicien touche après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo les gens sont ravis
avons alors plutôt content of le lobe
musique qu'il y ait du cola on va se
coucher
je vous accompagnent leurs enfants
[Musique]
aux musulmanes ne nourrit pony grands
musiciens aux données chiffrées
[Musique]
ce putt de coûts 1
bonne nuit nicolas bonnieu pas preneur
dans bien
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit nicolas bonne nuit
petit pimprenelle bonne nuit tous les
enfants allez vite vous coucher et
embrasser bien fort vos parents allons
en vous de grands virtuoses bonne nuit
pas de boer